We should tell him the truth
i did what i had to do to protect our world
it's pretty unfathomably exciting
where we're going in this film
it's the most fantastic new phase of marvel what
do you know about the multiverse this had his
theories he believed it was dangerous in this
story we are leaping into different universes
but unlocking the multiverse creates a big
pandora's box you open the doorway and we
don't know who or what will walk through it
we're in unknown territory i think audiences
are going to be startled these other realities
invite a plethora of all these new characters
telling the stories was such a gigantic
endeavor it had to be large because it
had to not only paint a picture of our universe
but of multiple universes we need your help it
was a great opportunity to pair two of
the most powerful superheroes together
it's got a sort of darker tone to it than with
sam remy at the helm and he's a master of that
we wanted the fans to go oh how
cool i mean that really was our goal
we wanted to give the fans what they
wanted just not exactly what they expected
the stakes are real he's literally
coming up against versions of himself
things just got out of hand
Welcome back everyone marvel dropped a brand new
doctor strange multiverse of madness trailer video
with a lot of the actors talking about their
characters so we'll break it all down there's
a bunch of new footage bunch of easter eggs so
if you're brand new to the channel we are doing
a giveaway for movie tickets all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and just leave all your
theories in the comments below one of the biggest
things you probably noticed during this featurette
is the way they've changed their marketing in the
stuff that they're not talking about like patrick
stewart's professor x they show you the multiverse
illuminati base there's a couple new scenes there
too that i'll talk about but during the footage
when they start talking about the villains and
the dangers of the multiverse benedict cumberbatch
is only talking about facing the other variants
of doctor strange as if they're meant to be the
villains like the big thing they're not talking
about is doctor strange versus scarlet witch a
lot of the footage they have in the older trailers
makes that way more clear so i'll point that out
as we go through this footage like what's actually
going on in this scene because in most of the
scenes they really only give you half of what's
actually going on but they open up with doctor
strange using the dark hole to perform this quote
unquote forbidden spell of the multiverse spell
that wong gets really pissed off at him about
all these different spheres that you see him
open up and then slam down on the dark hole
is probably related to opening a door to
the multiverse this probably after he goes
to wanda who has the dark holes as far as
we know at least until doctor strange takes
it from her asking about what she knows of
the multiverse and she starts referencing
vision talking about how dangerous it could be
both of them talk about these different dreams
that they keep having these waking nightmares
obviously different kinds of nightmares they're
talking about the nightmare that doctor strange
is talking about is visions of the multiverse
after the events of spider man no way home with
the multiverse almost collapsing around them
but it sounds like he starts to have visions of
this potential even worse outcome for reality so
he wants to find a way into the multiverse to try
and prevent that from happening but inadvertently
makes things even worse which is a very spider-man
type of problem like we joke about it not being a
spider-man movie if spider-man doesn't cause most
of the problems that he winds up having to solve
same idea with this doctor strange movie based
on some of that other footage of scarlet witch
telling doctor strange that she thinks it's
unfair that people think that she's the villain
because she breaks quote unquote some of the
rules and they think that he's a hero because
he breaks rules it sounds like there's a big
twist at some point during the movie where
doctor strange learns that it's really mcu
scarlet witch that he should be afraid of and
she's kind of been orchestrating events at least
up to a certain point to get him to use the dark
hole to open a door to the multiverse and a lot
of that has to do with america chavez and her
powers to open portals to different universes
that was one of the unexpected things the way
they're explaining it in this movie is that mcu
characters have not spent a lot of time traveling
physically to other universes this is meant to be
like one of the first big times that you actually
see them do that previously the way they explain
it is that you've seen other universes sort of
bleed into or come to our universe spiderman
no way home probably the best example that
characters from other universes coming to our
universe thank you very much for coming back
toby maguire and andrew garfield and the other
sinister six villains you know it's what we do
but part of what's supposed to be going on is
that scarlet witch really wants to go to another
universe to find a version of billy and tommy but
the way they're explaining in the mcu at least
is that as much power she does have with all this
chaos magic she cannot physically travel to other
universes without the help of america chavez she
winds up finding mcu doctor strange and wong after
she goes on the run through the multiverse and a
lot of this new footage kind of spells that out so
for example there's a scene here of them opening
this metal door this seems like it's actually
happening a little bit later in the film because
the christine palmer variant from the multiverse
illuminati is with them when they do that also
you have the scarlet witch variant wearing the
plain clothes just covered in oil in what looks
kind of like blood it might just be oil from the
ultron variant robots there's chaos magic just
billowing off of her and she's coming for them
like she wants their blood so this is all probably
happening after she winds up just wrecking
the entire multiverse illuminati base so rip
multiverse illuminati you're gonna be really cool
for the brief period that we see you on screen but
because of some of the other new footage when they
open this door to this weird multiverse looking
space we actually find out what is in the middle
here that bright light in the previous trailers
we can now clearly see is the actual book of the
vashanti if you're not a longtime doctor strange
comic book reader the vishanti are this trio of
really powerful cosmic beings including agamotto
the actual source for agamotto that wound up
creating the eye that doctor strange is wearing
when he opens the door using that special spell
you also notice when he's opening the door
it glows yellow instead of glowing green
because he doesn't have the time stone anymore
thank you very much older version of thanos
reduced to atoms but now you see them running
across these platforms through this really crazy
looking space like they're trying to get the book
of the vashanti as if it's some sort of counter to
the darkhold or whatever power scarlet witch has
during the movie you also see them being chased
by this giant creature that looks like it's laced
with chaos magic because it's going kind of red
it has the same runes on it that are on the
gargantos looking creature that's coming for them
earlier in the movie we can also now clearly
see that when it's yelling in america chavez
and forcing her to open this multiverse portal
behind her this is actually happening inside
this same crazy space with the book of the
vashanti like whatever this space winds up being
so her being forced to open the portal by mcu
scarlet witch probably has something to do with
her finally getting to an actual version of billy
and tommy for those of you asking about this scene
of this version of doctor strange being blasted by
magic this actually looks like a longer version of
the scene of mcu doctor strange versus sinister
strange inside his alternate sanctum that looks
all run down like he get a much better look of it
back here everything looks like it's gone to crap
as he grows that third eye and they start to
throw down he says things kind of got out of hand
so it's kind of the same thing with mcu scarlet
witch and the scarlet witch variant like scarlet
witch's variant isn't necessarily a bad person
but it sounds like she's being controlled by mcu
scarlet witch and whatever's going on with
the darkhold and because they all have this
really powerful chaos magic in all these different
universes each version of scarlet witch that you
run into winds up being a huge potential threat
so when wang gets really pissed off it mcu doctor
strange for opening the door quote unquote to
the multiverse that's what he's afraid of any
potential cosmic threat like dormammu but also all
these variants that could wind up being very evil
a lot of you've also probably noticed some of
the samuraimy specific easter eggs so there is
a pizza easter egg it's not the same pizza
place from the spider-man movies that was
joe's pizza because it was in a different
part of manhattan where that was happening
the license plate reads p307 usually the license
plates wind up being easter eggs for big stories
the only thing i could find is that avengers
307 was a big eternal storyline and obviously
there's a bunch of eternal stuff happening in
the background of the mcu right now the other
really cool sam raimi easter egg that a lot of you
will notice especially if you're a connoisseur of
a lot of his horror films especially the evil
dead series is the way the camera moves when
it's coming in on america chavez doctor strange
and wong here this is happening inside kamar taj
and it's when mcu scarlet witch is coming for
them and you see the camera zoom in on them and
tilt from side to side that's a horror movie
shot taken directly from the evil dead series
and the other really interesting scene here is
of mcu scarlet witch being attacked by what looks
like chaos magic bolts like it actually looks
like these red chaos magic bolts are firing at her
she's standing in the ruins of this building here
it's hard to tell if this is still kamar taj and
it's happening during the big attack earlier in
the film or if this is in the dark hole temple
a little bit later in the film the only ways i
think that happens is if her own magical attack
was reflected back at her or if she
were being attacked by the chaos magic
creatures protecting the darkhold temple here
it actually kind of seems like they're working
with them or if she's controlling them in some
way but if you spotted any new easter eggs in
this footage that i didn't talk about in the video
just write them in the comments below for those of
you asking about the thor 11 thunder trailer i
think they're probably going to wait till either
later this month or like really early next month
when they actually release doctor strange too
we just got a brand new look at christian bales
gore the god butcher so i'll probably do a video
for that at some point this week we also have a
brand new stranger things season 4 trailer coming
tomorrow so that should post next everyone click
here for my brand new doctor strange 2 wolverine
and x-men video and click here for my brand
new thor love and thunder first look video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one you!